in person on the Rich Eisen show someone
you've enjoyed in Southland and that
thing you do and also now in I'm sorry
on truTV renewed for a second season
every Wednesday at 10:00 Eastern and
9:00 Central right now good to see you
Tom Everett Scott thank you thanks for
having me so which what are your team's
what what sports teams are you a fan of
Thai grew up in East Bridgewater
Massachusetts so I'm a Boston fan oh boy
through yeah
everything everything hey tree 'it's
yeah even though yeah
Patriots Red Sox they follow really
closely I'm a Celtics and and Bruins fan
but I don't I don't follow it as close
okay so the Patriots were you there and
the the large seats of Foxborough back
in the Grogan days the Tony Eason days I
mean you go by was the fan back then
yeah Croghan what Grogan when he had
that neck brace on
Flutie was there Tony Eason the 86 Super
Bowl against the Bears was pretty yes
devastating sure but I'd never seen a
game at Foxborough I the only thing I'd
ever seen there was like soccer so you'd
never actually went to one of those
games as well no I never went to one of
those games so but so now you're diehard
Red Sox fan went to the first Red Sox
game when I was six with my dad so who
was who was playing well it was a George
boomer Scott Jim Ryan George boomer Rick
Burleson's
gosh yeah butch hobson butch hobson yeah
I'm sure he was there
he's on those teams right Brockman back
in the back in the 80s or we're back in
the 70s I was born yet Don Zimmer being
the manager of that team good old Zim
from back in that day yeah yeah it was
fun they lost to the Brewers that game
but I got some players to sign my
program and I was hooked ever so you
still have that program yeah my mom has
it at her house so who's on that program
I think those guys George Scott signed
it Burleson Robin Yount did you get the
other Jim Rice the signatures on home
rice now he's doing the game's on
Nessun in studio yeah yeah I love
watching them who's at Dan who's Dave
O'Brien Dave O'Brien right and then Remy
is gonna have filling in is Eckersley
who is tough to watch I love accuracy
but some
I just can't get behind cheese and the
other things that he says going Bridge I
was listening to the other night saying
things that he was saying things I
couldn't honest yet obviously rubs the
players the wrong way like David Price
yes I like it
Wow yeah yeah I like it when rocket gets
in the booth because he just really
he's great does he do that anywhere else
cuz Clemens is great to listen to I have
not heard him call a game he's fantastic
he did it went on WEEI when they were in
Houston this year playing the Astros he
filled in for Joe Castiglione I'm
kidding yeah he was he was awesome to
listen to dude so you're you're locked
in on these right I love okay I'm um I'm
from New York City so I'm the opposite
yep this is it this is it I I am right
now I'm just Afghans back I am through
the roof right now just two and a half
back but two in the lost column this is
gonna be great this for between the
Yankees and Red Sox starting on Thursday
at Yankee Stadium I know this is gonna
be great buckle up Tom Everett Scott
here on the Rich Eisen show so you're in
fantasy football couple leagues
including tonight you are drafting
tonight back from my college buddies
tonight okay so that's the league you
want to win right I wanna win them all
rich okay but yeah this is yeah this is
serious it's a 24 round draft it's kind
of clapping and come on 24 rounds tell
me Tom Tom so bad
come on your your your man with a career
you've got children yeah what am i doing
24 just a waste of my life no but it's
okay I mean you're into quarterbacks
three running backs four wide receivers
tight end and a kicker no defense and
then you have this massive bench so the
player pool is just a wasteland by the
time you start the season so is there
any keepers and there's no keepers so
you're starting from scratch tonight
with the 24 rounds yeah how many how
many seconds per round it's unlimited
dude it's unlimited picture I'm talking
oh my commissioner won't Bend on any
rules we haven't changed this since like
1995 that's your rule that's my rule
unlimited pick time to pick data so how
many teams are in this league ten okay
so that's not that but so that's 240
draft picks well time
trust me on my computer's open at home
I'm still like finding guys that I'm
gonna have to look for at the end of it
what time is a draft start 8 o'clock
Eastern Oh Eastern 5 ok so but so
there's gonna be someone the East Coast
staying up till 2:00 in the morning
mm-hmm something like that why do you
say that so matter-of-factly I just do
it now
I'm so used to this this is the night
that my wife is just like oh tonight so
who's the twenty fourth round pick I
mean like during like whoever's right
for like you were gonna be looking at
okay
well round forth running back exactly
who is it
let's see well they've got four net
they've got ivory in Yeldon yes the
fourth string running back for the
Jacksonville Jaguars so we can help out
Tom Everett Scott with his [ __ ] to drag
I'm gonna want that looks like well TJ
Yeldon is the third back Corey grant is
the fourth LaGrande a guy named Dhawan
Harris is the fifth bound Sean Harris
didn't place ivory still there he
obviously is the backup did do want
Harris play for the Packers you want hit
that that hyperlink right there just to
show how Tom Everett Scott knows what
you got yeah he played for the Packers
and the 49ers the last two years you're
out of your mind what's the name of your
team
electric boogaloo because okay it's my
second time in this league I dropped out
at one point and came back so it's the
sequel I see so it's an electric
boogaloo - Reagan - okay very good
I'm sorry on truTV every Wednesday at
10:00 Eastern Time it looks like you're
enjoying this this show and it's picked
up for season two it is I'm so excited I
love it so much well how much of this is
scripted a lot of it but a lot of its
improv and she is an incredible Andrew
savage yeah Andrea savage is a fantastic
writer our showrunner Joey Sleiman
writes with her as well and the two of
them have just made something very real
and funny truly funny mm-hmm I get to be
someone who is funny but by being
natural and you know which is what I
really like you know doing comedy in the
past where I had to really sell jokes I
don't
thing was something I was you know
wasn't my strong suit this is just being
real playing off of her right it's a
great environment yeah she's currently
playing the President on veep she's in
the coming season of Curb Your
Enthusiasm Laura she's month she is on
fire right now and it's a very funny
show and you are you are funny in it
that thing you do
1996 how old were you 26 26 and how did
you get involved with that movie I was
acting in New York I was auditioning
first off you know in the beginning of
my career and I went in for Tom Hanks
his directorial debut I just like read
for the casting director and he brought
me back to meet Tom and what was that
like it was extremely nerve-wracking but
Tom Hanks is one of the nicest people in
the world so he made me feel very
comfortable right dad did you know how
to drum do you have to learn how to
didn't on a drum but I put on my resume
on the back of my headshot I put special
skills I said guitar and trumpet and he
asked me if that was true because as an
actor he said he knew that that could be
a lie
thank you yeah and I said no it's true I
play both those instruments and he said
okay you know it you have some sense of
rhythm I'm hiring actors not musicians
we'll we'll do the music later right so
then once I got a cast I studied with a
teacher for like two months right and
it's it's a remote drop movie for me no
matter when I see it I got to watch it
to the very end and I cannot believe
that movie is 21 years old now I can't
believe it either but I love that it's
in that category for people that it's
it's a when you're changing channels and
you stop on it you know there's only a
few movies like that for me to you know
and so I like what is that for you in
Groundhog Day would be one I'm always
gonna watch that thing you do as well it
really is so terrific and then you know
the music executive is played by Alex
Rocco who was you know yeah Moe green
for crying out loud
yeah yeah that was that was a great that
must have been incredible all was so
much fun yeah yeah there were so many
great people in there mmm and then lala
land as well for you this this past year
yeah that was a wonderful experience I
was so happy to be considered for that
you know they needed somebody who you
wouldn't necessarily fully hate at the
end
obviously right at the very end and then
you know Congrats on winning best
picture for about somebody got their
speeches and thank-yous in something
else that was something else I was
watching with my wife we were getting
ready to go to an after-party and we
were in the middle of you know the shock
and I looked over in my teenage daughter
was filming me and I was like is that
what happens now and you're in the
middle of a moment you just look over
something's gonna your daughter's gonna
be filming you have you watched that
footage no snapchat it's gone oh gosh
see on forever sort of like the best
picture trophy I mean that was really
something you know I don't know it's not
so nice I shouldn't have said something
like that okay so good luck on your
draft
thank you mom I hope it's over before
season three more questions about depth
charts and score is this available he
just finished a draft in Boston where
there's no time limit yeah eight hours I
would never be part of something like
that if we heckle each other enough that
it doesn't last that long
oh we do my friends don't care so you
get together you're not doing this I
know we're doing it online it's mostly
guys on the East Coast okay good luck to
you and electric Boogaloo thank you Tom
Everett Scott come back any time brother
thank you good to see you the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about